it's over Anakin I have the high ground
you underestimate my power don't try it
you and my brother Lanigan I loved you
you were supposed to destroy the Sith
not join them yeah ring balance to the
force not leave it in darkness star wars
episode 3 Revenge of the Sith we are
back talking about the official episodes
of Star Wars last month was the Clone
Wars I had to get that out of the way I
had to talk about the Clone Wars in
between episode 2 and three because
chronologically that's where it takes
place also a little bit of a
misconception on that review I had a few
questions asking me hey why were you
only reviewing Clone Wars volume 1 and
not volume 2 I was reviewing both of
them I just held up volume 1 I didn't
think I had to hold up every volume in
their review I said you could watch the
whole thing in two hours these are both
an hour each and that's what I was
referring to the whole thing okay you
guys understand now and just like with
Phantom Menace and attack the clones
this is going to be a spoiler filled
review of Revenge of the Sith let's dig
into this thing this is the watchable
prequel in 2005 I was pumped out of my
mind for this movie it was finally the
one where we got to see Anakin turn into
Darth Vader it's what we signed up for
ever since Phantom Menace back in 99 it
was the story we wanted to see the whole
time it was also the first pg-13 Star
Wars and I knew I was like there's gonna
be some in this one some stuffs
gonna happen some people are gonna die
and people are gonna burn and oh my gosh
pg-13 Star Wars so I was so excited I
was there at the midnight release there
were people dressed up like obi-wan
Kenobi having lightsaber battles it was
awesome I rewatched this movie yesterday
and right from the opening scene the CGI
is already better than Episode one in
Episode two and not just because it's a
newer film than those films they
accomplished a lot more depth with the
look of space just in the opening scene
even today it still looks pretty good it
looks far better than the CGI in Episode
one and two I would
very pleased to discover that because I
haven't watched the movie in a couple
years that being said though it still
suffers from the same issue in regards
to dialogue as the first two the
dialogue is better in Episode three but
it still does feel wooden and forced
from time to time especially in the
opening few scenes I say patience
patience yes the magic of film is that
you watch events that are controlled and
planned yet they feel spontaneous if the
film is good and Revenge of the Sith
does feel largely resided over by
someone who's like telling everyone to
do certain things in a certain way and
make sure you say things exactly like
this and look here at just the right
moment it does feel controlled in that
way it doesn't have the spontaneity that
the original Star Wars films had but the
dialogue has improved over the first two
and the opening of this film Anakin
obi-wan and r2 are trying to rescue
Chancellor Palpatine who's been
imprisoned by Count Dooku and General
Grievous it's this big opening epic
action scene with a space battle
lightsaber fights and all honesty just
the opening of Revenge of the Sith is
better than the entirety of Episode two
the lightsaber battle just in this scene
was far better than the one at the end
of episode two and there's actually some
humor that works there's good banter
between obi-wan and Anakin and I've
always liked seeing artoo
blast these droids with oil and then
light that oil on fire with his
thrusters burning all the droids really
great moment actually now like I said
this opening introduces the character of
General Grievous and if you hadn't
watched the Clone Wars micro series
you'd have no idea who this was in fact
at the end of that series mace Windu
reaches out and crushes Grievous's chest
plate which gives him the coffee that he
has in Revenge of the Sith which I like
those little tidbits and supposedly the
first cut of Revenge of the Sith was
like four hours long and this opening
action scene was over an hour just by
itself and you can kind of tell as you
watch it that there are certain things
that are cut out and as I said the
opening lightsaber battle is better than
the one in Episode two especially the
moment where Anakin kills Count Dooku
and I love the way Palpatine says do it
you got a little bit of the Emperor in
there just a hint of it and there's this
great moment of silence after Anakin
decapitates Dooku first off it was
pretty violent for a Star Wars movie
and I really like the way it was handled
the sound effect was like this strange
echo e-blast of some kind and you just
got this moment like Anakin just did
some early on in the movie when
they're docking their ship if you look
just down the bottom right corner of the
frame you can see the Millennium Falcon
now I remember noticing that in theaters
and I almost shouted oh my god
Millennium Falcon but I just I kept my
mouth shut there's a cool little easter
egg and as I said the early CG battle
looked really great the CGI still holds
up fairly well but as soon as these
characters are walking around these blue
rooms and mace window is looking at
things and samuel l.jackson is trying to
act nothing it looks bad it really does
you can just tell as they walk through
these backgrounds these sets are not
real so Anakin learns that Padme is
pregnant and you can tell he's a little
iffy about this information he's not too
pleased with it and although the
dialogue in Revenge of the Sith has
definitely improved over the last two
films there are still some horrific Lee
atrocious moments you're so beautiful
it's only because I'm so in love and
ever since I saw this movie I have
always thought Natalie Portman looked
different in this scene I don't know
what it is just you have like no makeup
on is it like her eyebrows because she
just doesn't look like Natalie Portman
for some reason in that scene was it a
reshoot I don't know like it's always
bugged me it just doesn't look like her
to me is it just me I don't know and we
watching this movie yesterday it was
very apparent to me that this is the
story Lucas has wanted to tell this
whole time Anakin's turned towards the
dark side for real
Palpatine psychologically messing with
Anakin the twisting of his mind him
turning on his friends and his loved
ones this is the story Lucas has wanted
to tell and it's the story we've wanted
to see and you can really tell in the
screenplay in the dialog because
although some that is still very wooden
there is actually a compelling story in
this one and in all honesty it's pretty
smart the way George Lucas maneuvered
this story to get Anakin to want to turn
Palpatine recommending that Anakin be on
the council so Hannigan is all excited
about that but the council doesn't let
him be a master so Anakin's really upset
about that and Palpatine knew that they
would do that
in the council asks Anakin to spy on
Palpatine and Palpatine also knew they'd
asked him to do that plus there's this
whole thing about Anakin being worried
about Padme dying because he's getting
the same visions that he got of his
mother before she died so all these
pieces are being moved in just the right
way to manipulate Anakin and Lucas did a
really brilliant job with this story in
that regard it's very compelling and
every time I've watched this movie it's
such a little part but every time samuel
l.jackson does his little head nod to
Yoda on the ship his so corny I can't
help but laugh every time a prophecy
that misread could have been
one of the best scenes in the entire
film in fact it may be the best scene in
the movie is when Palpatine and Anakin
are sitting at some sort of concert or
circus-like event and Palpatine starts
to tell him about the tragedy of Darth
Plagueis the wise it's a legend of a
Sith that was able to save people from
death those he loved and cared about who
was eventually killed by his apprentice
in his sleep it's ironic you could save
others from death but not himself is it
possible to learn this power not from a
Jedi it's a great scene there is so much
backstory there another thing I really
loved about Revenge of the Sith was that
we finally got to see the wookie planet
a Wookiee armies taking on these droids
and Chewbacca's there he doesn't really
do anything though he can't just stands
on his legs and Yoda hops on his
shoulder in one shot and that's awesome
so obi-wan finally tracks down Grievous
and I like how he just jumps in he just
wants to take everyone on by himself
he's like totally is like just you guys
are nothing I'm gonna fight Grievous and
grievous pulled out four lightsabers and
I remember my jaw dropped I was like oh
my gosh how can you even do anything
with that that's crazy I'll be one come
on now man and the first time I saw this
movie I was like whoa obi-wan just did
the two fingered Vegeta point come on
now will be one that's Vegeta's don't
steal it during this fight between
obi-wan and grievous though impressive
though it might be there was a horrific
ly bad close-up of obi-wan where he's
just like oh I don't think so and zooms
it on his eyes and it's all like
off-center I'm like what where did that
come from it was really cool and then
that happened oh I don't think so now in
the next scene Ian McDermott really
rocks it as he finally admits to Anakin
that he knows the ways of the dark side
are you going to kill me now I would
certainly like to I know
I can feel your anger it gives you focus
basically all the scenes with Palpatine
enticing Anakin to go to the dark side
are actually really good I was very
pleased to be watching this movie and I
love how obi-wan kills Grievous with a
blaster just throws on the ground he's
like so uncivilized
and I've always thought the silence of
Anakin and Padme staring at each other
across the city was very powerful
although it does look like one shot in
this scene was reversed this one in
particular
as someone who does a lot of editing I
can tell that the way his eyelid opens
looks as if they've reversed the flow of
that shot might just be me but it looks
reversed to me
so once Anakin tells mace windu that he
believes that Palpatine is the Sith Lord
they've been looking for mace windu
confronts Palpatine and a light saber
battle ensues and it's well pretty
terrible a lot of this you can tell is
due to ian McDermott's lack of skill
with this idea of lightsaber stunt work
he's doing all these weird faces and
he's just kind of stabbing it like hey
I'm like what the hell are you doing man
it just doesn't work because you can
really tell that they're trying to edit
around the CGI head of MacDermid being
on a stunt guy and then MacDermid doing
weird little movements you're like what
it was a big letdown it doesn't sell
that this man is the most powerful Sith
in the entire galaxy he just kind of
looks like an older gentleman who's
trying to swing around one of those
plastic bats now my main issue with
Revenge of the Sith is Anakin's actual
turn once he decides to become Darth
Vader in this next scene Palpatine is
shooting lightning at mace Windu he's
electrocuting himself as mace windu
blocks it with a lightsaber and Anakin's
like no we need we need to try him we
need I need him because Padme oh my god
cut off Mace Windu's hand mace Windu
dies gets shot out of a window and then
Anakin just goes like I pledged myself
to your teachings I understand the
motivation I understand messing with him
psychologically it just felt a little
abrupt and Palpatine's all deformed now
all of a sudden he doesn't really seem
that shocked about I mean if I were him
I'd be like holy crap my face is
but we as an audience are expecting
Palpatine to eventually look like this
so it wasn't surprising for us to see
that but him as a character as a person
probably should have had a moment of
shock when he realized that his entire
face is now like some monster the next
sequence in which order 66 is carried
out and the clone troopers turn on the
Jedi and all of the other good guys is
extremely effective I love this shot
where it pans down to the troopers boots
and they just stop following the Jedi
it's a great moment it's really sad John
Williams music you see all these people
dying I love how they took their voices
screaming and they echoed them you know
like it was some sort of fantasy almost
like it's not actually happening but it
is happening Master Skywalker there are
too many of him what are we going to do
yeah Anakin kills some children he kills
all the younglings I mean that's some
dark stuff right there I mean yeah it's
a little cutesy the way the kid came out
with cyclonic adil Master Skywalker well
we go wow I come on but also I noticed
something here in Revenge of the Sith
this is the first time in the entire
prequel saga that Yoda shows any emotion
at all what he says goodbye Chewbacca
wish you I will and then finally we hear
Yoda steam from John Williams finally
the thing we love the thing it's so
emotional and you're just like oh yes
Yoda
because that was the only little bit of
emotion we finally got out of Yoda and
John Williams is like ah finally Yoda
emotional put Yoda's theme in there
finally thank you and then all of a
sudden Wow is that a Star Wars set are
we finally on a Star Wars set thank you
and it's really powerful to finally see
Anakin carrying out all these dark deeds
his eyes are changing colors he's
assassinating people left and right I
just think that Obi Wan's realization
that Anakin is behind it there isn't
enough real shock or emotion in his
voice or on his face he's just sort of
like I can't watch any mole and he turns
off the security hologram we'll talk
more about that security hologram in a
second there just wasn't quite enough of
a realization or that moment where he's
like in denial it was just like oh
that's what are we gonna do about Anakin
that's pretty bad
it's so quick it's really abrupt and
like I said the next scene Padme is not
believing anything obi-wan is saying
about Anakin's new way of acting and
he's like I have seen a security
hologram of Anakin killing younglings
it's Lou that's Lucas dialogue right
there watching these prequels again and
knowing about the changes they've made
to the originals Lucas has always had a
tough time conveying emotion through his
characters without just having them say
what they feel he loves when people
scream no
or when Padme goes next Anakin you're
breaking my heart he has
thing where he's like I need people to
say what they're feeling because you can
never actually convey emotion without
saying it I think that's what he
struggles the most with in his writing
he's afraid that people are not going to
understand what he's trying to convey
unless they say it directly to the
audience and as this final confrontation
between Anakin and obi-wan is about to
start some of Hayden Christensen's line
delivery is just atrocious if you're not
with me then you're my enemy yeah well
not take on prom night so we get to the
big finale where Anakin and obi-wan are
finally dueling on Mustafar the lava
planet and Yoda and the Emperor are also
dueling and it's pretty cool although
incredibly choreographed to the point of
absurdity you just don't get the sense
that two people are actually fighting in
regards to Anakin and obi-wan it looks
like they're dancing that intensity that
was in Empire Strikes Back is not there
because you can just tell they're
executing all of their moves perfectly
as they were told to through their
choreography and it goes on and it goes
on and on and on there just isn't enough
dialogue in between these lightsaber
battles there isn't enough suspense in
between all the fencing it's just a lot
of crazy flipping and moves but right
before Yoda battles the Emperor I've
always loved how he just walks in the
room and he's like yeah and just swipes
these two guards against the wall
knocked him out instantly like nothing
and the fight between Anakin and obi-wan
just goes on and on to the point of
absurdity where they're now floating on
these lava droids and Anakin looks like
he's part of a player select screen in a
video game choose your player and
finally towards the end of this scene
obi-wan does like a backflip on this
little rock mass and he's now above
Anakin and he's like it's over Anakin I
have the high ground I seem to remember
a moment in the Phantom Menace in which
Obi one most certainly did not have the
high ground had something to do with
Darth Maul someone got shot in half
they're 2 1 so B 1 does defeat Anakin
cuts him in half and he starts to burn
in the lava below the emotion conveyed
through Obi Wan's great I just wanted
more
that during the actual lightsaber battle
which is just like SuperDuper Jedi guys
you and my brother Anakin I loved you
you were supposed to destroy the Sith
not join them bring balance to the force
not leave it in darkness and him picking
up the lightsaber that he eventually
gives to Luke in Episode four was also a
cool little tidbit and apparently Padme
has completely lost the will to live
there's no reason she'd be dying she
just she's lost the will to live uh I
don't know I'll accept it Anakin was
just born from nothing I guess so
whatever it is however pretty brilliant
that Lucas intercut Anakin being
operated on the birth of Darth Vader
with the birth of his children with
Padme those scenes cut together make for
a really sad moment you can really feel
it it's just like oh that's in the heart
right there deep in the fields I've also
always loved as the helmet is lowering
to Anakin he has this look of fear that
suddenly crosses his face like he isn't
very happy about this and that is really
great it adds more depth to Darth Vader
and hearing James Earl Jones speak as
Darth Vader was like hearing what heaven
sounds like so incredible it's just they
needed more more dialogue there's a
couple sentences that's it and then he
does that stupid terrible no I'm just
like there's Lucas again not being able
to convey emotion unless someone's
saying it seriously when I saw that in
theaters people laughed it just it
didn't work the last few scenes in the
movie are really just connection scenes
linking three and four the babies are
safe Luke goes to Tatooine Leia goes
with senator Organa obi-wan is now in
exile on Tatooine and Yoda is in exile
on Dagobah
in all honesty re watching this movie I
like Revenge of the Sith it is a lot
better than one and two there's actually
a compelling story this time around when
we all heard the prequels were happening
and it was going to be about Anakin
Skywalker this was the story we all
wanted to see from the beginning and we
finally got to see it and Lucas wasn't
afraid to go dark with this movie and I
liked that about this film there are
still a lot of problems with the
dialogue the romantic stuff is just bad
I'm going to give Star Wars Episode
three Revenge of the Sith of bee
we made it through the prequels guys we
did it I'm so excited
next month I get to talk to you guys
about episode for a new hope I'm going
to tell you all about how much that
movie inspired me as a kid and how
important that movie was to my life and
I can't wait to do so as always thank
you so much for watching guys and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes